翻訳: Riaki Poništ
校正: Reiko Bovee
皆さん こんにちは
（観客）こんにちは
（森田洋之）白衣の男が出てきました
僕は誰でしょう
（笑）
医者です
医者が出てきたってことで
新しい治療法だったり
新しい健康法だったり
そんないい話が
聞けるんじゃないかなと
お思いかなと思います
でも今日は 僕はそういう話は
残念ながらしません
じゃあ何を話すか
実は これです
［医療崩壊のすすめ］
おかしいですよね
（笑）
医者が医療崩壊すすめて
どうすんだと
僕も思います
僕も本当は 医療崩壊を
すすめたいわけでは ありません
じゃあ 何でこんなことを
僕は言ってるか
実はですね
僕は医者になる前
経済学部を卒業してます
で 一から
医学部に入り直して
卒業して
医者になりました
もちろん経済も良かったんですけど
何か 直接
人の役に立てる仕事って
何かないかなぁと思って
医者になりました
で 医師免許取って
僕は内科医なので
大きな病院で胃カメラしたり
そういうことをしました
そうすると
他の病院の先生—
病院の中の他の先生から
「うちの患者さん
ご飯食べられなくなったから
先生 胃カメラできるから
胃ろうを入れてくれないか」
そんな話が
よく来るようになりました
胃ろうっていうのは
皆さんご存じかもしれないんですけども
こうやって お腹に穴をあけて
直接 胃に栄養を送る
そういう栄養法です
僕も最初は全然
うまくできなかったんですけど
何例も何例もやっていくうちに
だんだん上手になってきた
他の先生からも
「上手くなったね」とか
「上手になったね」とか言われて
得意になってた時期がありました
そんなときに
近くの高齢者施設に行ったら
すごくショックだったことがありました
それは 病棟を—
ほとんどの病棟にいる患者さんが
ほとんど寝たきりで
胃ろうされていた
そして その患者さんは
ほとんど意識がない
寝たきりで 意識がなくて
会話もできない
「痛い」も「痒い」も言えない
その状態で何年も
長生きは10年以上です
その状態を見たときに
僕は本当にショックを受けました
医者をやめようかなとも思いました
人の役に立とうと思って
医者になった
それなのに まったく人の役に
立ってるという実感が湧かなかった
僕は医者をやめようと思いながら
悩んでいました
そのとき ちょうどですね
北海道の夕張市ってとこが
財政破綻して
医療崩壊して
そこで 頑張っている
村上先生って人が
予防医療とか そういうので
頑張ってるということで
救いを求めて 夕張に行きました
今日は そんな話をしようかな
と思っております
さあ 夕張市
皆さん ご存知ですか
北海道の だいたい
真ん中あたりにあります
札幌がここなので
北海道の中では
かなり近い方なんですけど
でもこれもですね
60キロあります
60キロっていうと
鹿児島で言えば だいたい
錦江湾１つ 丸々入るくらい
それぐらいの距離ですね
意外と遠いですね
そう見るとね
で 夕張と言えば 皆さん
メロンですね
そのとおり
メロン そして
さっき言った財政破綻
この２つで有名ですね
でも 実は
一番大事なものがあります
これ日本一なんですけど
これ有名じゃない
でも一番大事だと思います
何でしょう
実は 高齢化率
［45.6％］
高齢化率が45％です
日本一です
今 日本全体が25％なら
ほぼ倍ですね
これだけ高齢者が多い—
日本一高齢者が多いところで
普通に考えたらですよ
医療は充実してくれなきゃ
いけないって考えますよね
でも さっき言ったように
医療崩壊してしまった
「医療崩壊」
一言で言いますけど
具体的にはこういうことです
［夕張市の病床数］
それまでは 夕張市内に
総合病院が１つあって
171床
それが医療崩壊
財政破綻によって
市がお金を「もう出せないよ
市立病院は継続できません」ていうことで
小さな診療所19床になりました
病床は ほぼ10分の1ですね
もちろん 医者も去りました
医療機器もですね
何と今は
夕張市内に
CT、MRI１台もない
０台です
市内にですよ
病院にじゃなくて
しかも 救急病院もなくなった
救急病院がなくなるということは
こういうことです
救急車が病院まで到着する時間
それまで30分台だったんだけど
なんと ほぼ２倍
60分台になりました
もちろん ちょっとした風邪とか
発熱ぐらいだったら
市内の診療所で僕らが診ます
ただ 例えば心筋梗塞
例えば交通事故で大怪我したとかね
そうなったとき
札幌の病院まで
ドクターヘリで行ってもらいます
となると 必然的に
時間は伸びますよね
じゃあ この状況で
夕張市民 生活できると思いますか？
不安でしょうがないですよね
でも僕が行ってみたら
夕張市民は すごく元気でした
どういうことか
例えば この人
（笑）
お若く見えますけど
実はですね
60代です
60代の女性
もうすぐ お孫さんが中学生です
すごいですよね
この人は 診療所の近くで
床屋さんをやってて
町の中心人物ですね
夜な夜な この人の家で
飲み会が開催されるという
もちろん僕も参加する
そこで どんな話がされるかというと
「今日は何歩 歩いた
何万歩 歩いた」
「今日は雪かきを何時間した」
「血圧は こんだけ今
下がってるぞ」とかですね
「私はガンを早期発見して治療した」
とかですね
そういう いい話ばっかり聞くんですね
で この人は何をやってるかというと
先ほどから ちょっと
不思議に思ってると思いますけど
「私は病院は絶対行かない」
「医者は嫌いだ」って
言うんですね この人
「もちろん 大きな病気とか
大きな怪我とかしたときは
お医者さんのとこ行くけども
それまでは 私はできるだけ
自分の免疫力を頼りに
免疫力を上げる
そのためにストレッチをやるんだ」
って言って
座布団を こうやって押しのけて
ストレッチをしてくれてる姿が
これですね
そこを僕が激写したと
（笑）
でも CTもMRIも医療機器も
すべての医療機器
道具です
健康で長生きするための
道具ですよね
もし それがなくても
健康が保たれるのであれば
それは非常に素晴らしいことです
近くに病院が 総合病院がある
ということよりも
市民が意識を変えるっていうことは
病院があること以上に
価値があることだと僕は思います
50代 60代 元気な人
まあいいでしょう
じゃあ 80代 90代の
じいちゃん ばあちゃん
さすがに病院がなかったら
不安でしょうがないんじゃないかと
思いませんか
思いますよね
この方 90代の女性
ばあちゃんですね
この方 まだ
お元気な頃の写真
この人 診療所で
肺に影が見つかって
札幌の病院で検査しました
そしたら CTとか色々検査したら
肺がんが見つかったんですね
肺がんが見つかったら 普通は
抗がん剤をやるとか
入院して治療しましょうって
話になります
もちろん そういう話を
されたそうですが
このばあちゃん 何と
その一回札幌に行って
検査したきり
二度と行かなかった
夕張に帰って
最後まで生活しました
その亡くなる直前の写真がこれ
すごく いい笑顔ですよね
亡くなる前の日の晩まで
まんじゅう食べてたそうです
好きなものを食べて
ご家族に囲まれて
地域の人々に囲まれながら
最後まで生活することを
この人は選んだということですね
こんなことをしてたら
こういう高齢者が
いっぱい いるわけです
よくよく考えたら
僕が総合病院時代に感じていたこと
胃ろうの方が
いっぱい いるような世界
夕張では そういう高齢者は—
生き生きとしていない高齢者は
一人もいませんでした
ただ これは僕の印象です
何か すごい世界が
広がってるなぁと思ってましたけど
実は 印象だけじゃなくて
数字にも出ました
例えばこれです
救急車の出動回数
下がっちゃったんですね
ちなみに全国的には
この10年でほぼ1.5倍
高齢化率が
高まれば高まるほど
救急車の出動回数が
どんどん増える
普通に考えたら
そうだと思います
でも高齢化率 日本一の夕張市
高齢化率
下がってんじゃないですよ
まだまだ上がってんですよ
２年 ３年前は43％でした
今45％
まだまだ 上がってる
でも なんと
こうなっちゃいました
［救急車出動回数］
ほぼ半分ですね
救急車が呼ばれなくなった
どういうことか
さっきのばあちゃん
救急車呼ばないんです
何でか
だって もう命を
命の終わりを受け入れてるんですね
救急車ってのは
この命を助けてくれという叫びのもとに
呼ばれるものですよね
あのばあちゃんは
助けてくれと思ってないんです
最後まで自分の家で
生活したいと思ったんです
だから呼ぶのは
訪問看護師 在宅医
もちろん 発熱とか
一時的なことで
まぁ これは
良くなるよってことであれば
家で点滴したり
座薬使ったり 治療します
でも そうでないときは
残念ながら お看取りすると
そういう世界です
だから救急車が減る
しかも 医療費も
減っちゃったんですね
高齢者１人あたり医療費
全国的には
ものすごい勢いで増えてます
［高齢者一人あたり医療費］
さぁ 夕張市は
なんと一時より
だいぶ下がった
［83万円→73万円］
すごいですよね
たぶん 救急車が減るとか
高齢者の医療費が減るとか
そういう地域って 全国でも
ほとんどないと思います
でも夕張市はできた
しかもですね
なんと 死亡率まで
下がっちゃったんですね
これがすごいです
［疾患率死亡率
医療崩壊！］
日本人の死因の１位がガン
２位が肺炎
違うこれ ２位が心臓ですね
で ３位が肺炎
ワン・ツー・スリー
全部下がっちゃった
すごいですよね
何がポイントか
たぶん 僕が思うに
予防の意識ですね
市民が予防の方に意識を変える
［予防］
「病院があるから安心」
ではなくて
「しっかり自分で
できることはやるんだ」と
予防の意識
日本人の病気の大部分は
生活習慣病から起きてるといいます
だったら 生活習慣を
変えればいいじゃないですか
みんな分かってるけど できない
あと もう１つ
終末期医療
［終末期］
残念ながら
日本人の死亡率は100％
日本人だけじゃないですけどね
いずれ 医療が解決できない問題が
やってきます
その時に しっかりと終末期の
イメージを持ってるか持ってないか
家族と話し合ってるか
話し合ってないか
地域の人たちと
そういう話をしてるか
もう もちろんですね
文章にまとめてればいいんですよ
リビングウィルとか
そこまでなくても
地域で話をしている
家族で話をしている
その事実があるだけでも
結果は全然違うと思います
さらに 地域社会ですね
若いときは予防の意識を高める
地域のみんなで予防の意識を高める
そして 歳を取ってきたら
みんなで 地域みんなで
その命を受け止める
そういう暖かい地域社会を作る
これがポイントだと思います
じゃあ これ
「夕張市民だから できたんでしょ」
よく言われるんです
「夕張は財政破綻したから
夕張市民だから
できたんでしょ」って
鼻で笑われることがあります
「一緒にするな」と
でも 確かにですよ
夕張市民は危機感があったから
できたかもしれない
じゃあ 僕らは 日本人
危機感を持たなくていいのか
僕は 危機感を持ったほうが
いいと思います
なぜならば 今
国全体の借金は
1200兆円って言われてますね
中央政府と地方自治体の
借金合わせたら1200兆円
これを１人あたりにすると
１人１千万
皆さん１千万万
負債を抱えています
ただ 今 生まれたばかりの赤ん坊と
90代のじいちゃん ばあちゃんを比べたら
やっぱり そこは
赤ん坊は これから長く
返していかなきゃいけない
差はありますよね
となると
今 生まれてきた赤ん坊は
生まれた瞬間に 何と
8300万円の借金を背負った状態で
生まれてくるという
計算をする先生もいます
しかも これは現時点の数字です
これから高齢化率は
どんどん増える
今 日本が ここです
25％
数十年後には40％になります
じゃあ 高齢化率が２倍になったら
借金も２倍になるんですか
医療費は どんどん上がってますもんね
ちなみに夕張は今ここです
［夕張は今ここ
日本は今ここ］
かなり先取りしてますね
でも 日本中がいずれ
夕張みたいに
高齢化率が高くなる
じいちゃん ばあちゃんばっかりになる
そんな世界になります
しかも これから人口は
どんどん減るらしいです
今までの百年は
異常な百年でした
それまで ずっと
１千万 ２千万 ３千万で
ほぼ横ばいだったのに
この百年で
なんと１億２千万になった
これから こうなるらしいです
良くて半分 悪いと
３分の１ ４分の１
今までの意識で 今後の百年を
乗り切れるという保証はないですね
意識を変えなきゃいけない
病院が欲しい 何々が欲しい
「あれも欲しい これも欲しい」
っていう時代から
「病院がなくても やっていけるよ」
っていうような時代に
なっていくべきじゃないかなと思います
じゃあ 日本
もう未来はないのか
そんなことはないと思います
これ見てください
日本は高齢化率
ずっと世界一なんです
これからも
日本だけじゃないですよ
世界中が高齢化率がどんどん上がっていく
さらに これ『エコノミスト』っていう
雑誌の表紙ですけど
［日本の抱える重荷］
日の丸に押しつぶされてます
こんなショッキングなことを
特集されるのも
日本が注目されているからです
世界中が解決できない高齢化問題
日本は その世界一なんです
日本に世界中が注目してます
だから こんなこと言われるんですね
じゃあ どうするか
これが医療費ですけど 世界中
医療費が どんどん上がってます
アメリカ フランス
カナダ イギリス
これからも高齢化率は
どんどん高くなる
たぶん こうなるでしょう
じゃあ どうするか
夕張はこうなったんです
下げられた
じゃあ日本も夕張の真似すれば
いいんじゃないですか
そしたら こうなる
もしこうなったら
世界中が びっくりしますよね
世界中から尊敬される
高齢化社会対策をできる—
日本になれると思います
これ 僕は「夕張モデル」って
言ってますけど
これからは「日本モデル」に
しないといけないなと思ってます
［夕張モデル→日本モデル］
そんな思いで
僕は九州に帰ってきました
2007年 夕張市が
財政破綻したとき
「夕張市民どうなっちゃうんだろう」
「かわいそうだな」と
思いませんでしたか
僕は九州で思ってました
でも もしかしたら 今
かわいそうなのは僕らかもしれない
夕張市民は分かった
でも僕らは もしかしたら
気づいてない
もしかしたら 気づいていない
ふりをしているだけかもしれない
日本が世界のリーダーになれる
鹿児島は明治時代に
日本を変えた実績を持っています
鹿児島が変われば日本が変わる
日本が変われば世界が変わると
僕は勝手に思っています
何か こう考えると
ワクワクしますよね
軍事力でもなく 政治力でもなく
経済力でもなく
高齢化対策で
日本は世界のリーダーになる
そんなことを僕は考えてます
一緒に ワクワクしながら
世界を変えてみませんか
ご静聴ありがとうございました
（拍手）